well it's just gone 1500 GMT and we
start this news hour with breaking news
from Russian controlled Crimea Moscow
says Ukrainian missiles have targeted
the headquarters of the Black Sea Fleet
in the peninsula said Russian air
defense systems shot down five missiles
during the attack in sevastopol but
black smoke has been seen billowing from
the base crimea's Russian banked
Governor has urged civilians to remain
indoors and stay away from the city
center until further notice in recent
weeks Ukraine has stepped up its attacks
on Russia's Navy Julia shapovalova is
standing by in Moscow but first let's
talk to Zan basravi he's live for us in
Kiev so first of all zann how
significant are these attx in analyzing
how Ukraine's military abilities are
evolving well Sammy just before I get
into that a bit of developing new news
from sevasti in the last 20 or 30
minutes we've heard of a second set of
explosions or at least one loud
explosion from sasta these reports
coming out it's unclear whether or not
this was an unexploded missile or a new
strike there were reports in the Russian
media that there were efforts being made
to remove some kind of unexploded
ordinance but in the last half an hour
we have heard of of another loud
explosion in sevastopol now as far as
technology you are correct technology
has been very important in this war
right from the beginning what we're
looking at this attack today illustrates
really how far Ukraine has managed to
come in the last year if you remember
last year there was an effort to carry
out a sea drone uh attack on sasap Pole
now that was unsuccessful when Elon Musk
turned off starlink that's been widely
reported that did raise the alarm Bells
here in keev the Pentagon since then
taking over uh the implementation of
starlink related operations ations here
in Ukraine and now we're seeing a very
successful by Ukrainian accounts a very
successful attack today with a variety
of missiles now there are reports that
drones were used that the uh land to see
Neptune missile that Ukraine develops in
country was modified in some way and
used during this attack we've also heard
reports that the British French Storm
Shadow missiles were a part of this
operation exactly what has happened
exactly how many were fired how many
were shot down that's something that
military bloggers from both sides of
this conflict are still debating but
what both sides agree on is that the
headquarters of the Black Sea fleet was
indeed hit images showing a great deal
of Destruction to that very important
Landmark the Black Sea Fleet being the
main thrust of military operations in
Ukraine since the Russian invasion and
this will no doubt be seen as a major
hit uh for uh the Russians operating out
of Sebastapol now in terms of
technological advancement Ukraine
Ukrainian operations that have been
going on across the country but
specifically on the Crimean peninsula in
the last two weeks the last 30 days do
show an uptick in their capability to be
able to take the fight to Russian
positions and it goes along with
something that President Vladimir
zalinsky said even before he left for
the UN General Assembly in New York he
said man-to-man the Russians do
outnumber the ukrainians but
technological advancement technological
help from its allies will help Ukraine
turn the tide and that seems to be what
we are seeing out of these attacks today
all right good stuff there let's thank
Zan basravi let's continue this though
with Yulia shapovalova she's live for us
in Moscow so what a Russian officials
saying about just how damaging this
attack
was well according to official reports
the Ukrainian Armed Forces launched a
missile attack on the headquarters of
the Russian Black Sea Fleet Russia's or
pre's assd we can say according to the
ministry of Defense in total five
missiles were shot down by air defense
systems during the repelling of that
tack uh one soldier went missing uh the
civilian infrastructure around the
headquarters building and the people on
the streets were not harmed uh the
police caued of the territory around the
headquarters uh the debr from the triack
was scattered over hundreds of meters
there and now the fragments of the DED
missiles are being collected uh
firefighters are also still
extinguishing the fire there and
emergencies Ministry of officers are
working on this pot uh law enforcement
officials have asked local residents to
avoid the Central Street of sopal the
shock wave of a missile attack shattered
windows in 10 residential buildings so
that's what the situation there looks
like after Russia's Black Sea Fleet
headquarters have been
targeted all right thanks so much Julia
shaal there